normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
the New York Post I'm going to start by
saying this ashree Derek shovin
railroaded Derk chauvin's foes will stop
at nothing to punish xop as he's nearly
killed in prison yo this dude certainly
does not deserve any of this and it's
very obvious that the government is
sacrificing him for their own protection
because they are
because they are evil people we saw this
with the armed Arbury case as well we're
seeing it now with Derrik chovin he was
nearly killed shortly after his appeal
to the Supreme Court was rejected and it
and and I think the reason is our
Supreme Court people need to understand
they're always like oh we got this great
conservative Supreme Court oh they're
cowards dude Thomas and Alo are based AF
and uh that's fantastic but the rest of
them are cowards who are terrified of
actually doing anything think of you
know it's just I'm sorry man American
culture is in shambles it's in Decay we
have a generation several generations
with too many spineless spineless
leaders and it's sad but it is what it
is and so this is the story now chovin
appeals Supreme Court they say no
shortly after he's nearly killed listen
we can all argue yeah you shouldn't
kneel on a guy's back and neck to
whichever argument you want to make fine
whatever if it was on the neck say don't
kneel on the neck he was trained to do
it he showed up after Floyd was already
on the ground he said in in in in an
interview that they were waiting for the
ambulance to come it didn't come he
could have certainly taken his knee off
the neck of the guy who was clearly not
breathing there's a lot of things he did
wrong and for that you get fired you get
involuntary manslaughter which is like
maybe two years probation never be a cop
again the city is forced to pay out a
settlement and the training practice of
kneeling on someone's back or neck
instead they claim this guy as an evil
evil racist who intentionally murdered a
black man blah blah blah all that stuff
ferally indict him lock him up and throw
away the key and then someone tries to
kill him if this is allowed to stand
like there's no justice in this country
okay because you can argue let's say
you're you're the most Fringe far
leftest person if you would argue and
and many of them are laughing that he
was attacked saying well that's you get
I'm like okay you're fascists and you're
evil you cannot like the guy you can
have the opinion he's an evil man who
did wrong and still even if you do
understand that proper Justice requires
he not die being murdered in prison or
imprisoned for the rest of his life in
multiple charges yeah and the argument
for a while was if he was in federal P
prison he's safer right that the idea
and this was in the Amed oper case this
the father son do were sentenced to
State Prison after they asked they got
convicted on Federal and State charges
they asked to be sent to sent to federal
prison for their own safety and they
were denied they're sent to State Prison
because right they they want ultimately
I think a lot of progressive uh AGS in
this country really want to see a bloody
end for these people and that's horrible
and sad and the judge in uh Chin's case
was like well if he's going to go to
federal prison put him somewhere his
family can see him right and he's their
families between Iowa and Minnesota and
they were like no Arizona we'll see you
later and now they're not giving the
family information about his status
they're learning about it as the news
updates which is crazy well that's what
his mom said and then the judge also had
come out and said that they were
surprised that chovin was trans referred
to Arizona and that it was done without
their awareness or knowledge of it but
the the the Bureau of Prisons doesn't
have to take a judge's recommendation uh
which is I mean maybe that's good maybe
that's bad in this case I think it's
pretty awful because did you guys see
fall of Minneapolis did you guys watch
that no what is it it's this uh
documentary it was a crowdsource
documentary about this case and
everything that happened in the riots
after George Floyd and what went what
went down it's actually pretty
interesting but they talked to um the
other cops in the case and all of them
are like no that we we did what our
training was you know the autopsy um uh
showed that there were drugs that it was
like most likely an overdose oh this
this is the one where they mentioned the
FBI interfere with the uh medical
examiner report right and that the body
cam footage wasn't released for months
which we knew at the time because that
was like everyone kept waiting for the
body cam footage to come out and it
never did and then it was just months
and months later after the government
had full contr of the narrative right
and the implication was like a gang of
white cops who had you know assaulted it
wasn't it was like an Asian guy there
was a black guy you know it was like the
makeup of the city was in little unit
they even locked up the dude who was
simply holding back a crowd MH that's
crazy like that that guy had no idea
what was even going on he was like guy
everyone stay back stay back and so now
he's going to jail for for a long time
well nothing nothing ever is going to
happen unfortunately positive for for
Chavin nothing is going to happen
positive if it does you'll have you'll
have that summer of love all over again
so maybe something does happen actually
actually maybe something does happen and
that's what the the left is going to use
to push the pandemonium in the summer of
2024 just before the although pardon
them Trump should par he can't pardon
him in Minneapolis he no he can Federal
chares yeah the federal case so when
Trump's president he can issue a pardon
do you think we're going to see riots
this summer yes what are they going to
be over immigration immigration riots no
race uh every four years uh you know on
Election years so uh 2020 Summer can you
can you believe it it's been over 3
years I cannot even believe wild right
when the summer The Summer of Love was I
love that that's what it's called who
who was it who said that it was Jenny
Durkin it was the mayor of Seattle
Summer of Love what a turd she is just
the
worst she also said that the uh Chaz the
CH the Seattle autonomous Zone she also
said it was like a big block party yeah
with people being killed with with
black teenagers 14-year-olds in 2020 who
weren't paying attention will be voting
next year yeah wow and they're voting
for Trump apparently Trump's up 46 to uh
what is it he's up he's up four points I
think against Biden according to NBC
News in the youth vote let's break that
down for a second because I I was
looking at this the other day so Trump
is up in the 18 to 34 vote I think he's
up right think he's okay he's up uh he's
getting right now I think they he's it's
a what what how do they describe it NBC
news said Biden minus four that's what
they said okay well so the the overall
poll like the the total of the poll I
think had Trump winning by like four
points if you go through the individual
categories I think the black vote Trump
was around 24% which is insane he got
12% in NBC News I I'm talking about yeah
let me let's pull it up I have
screenshots of it because I was arguing
this with somebody but uh Trump was had
about 20 I think it was 24% of the black
vote which is awesome because I think he
got 12% in 2020 he was uh Plus plus six
away from or he was six points away from
Biden in the Hispanic vote I think it
was like 42 to 48 M or something like
that he lost the Hispanic vote by 32
points in 2020 so Trump is up 12 points
on the on the black vote he's pulled
within he's he's cut 26 points on the
Hispanic vote he's winning the 18-34
vote and the overall poll only had him
winning by like three points or four
points or something like that are you
insane like if if you tell any
Republican those numbers for a
republican candidate and you don't tell
them it's Donald Trump they're like oh
my that's a that's a Ronald Reagan 19 uh
1980 Landslide I mean it's it's he wins
all 50 states he takes Minnesota too
that would be great are there any plac
they're saying Trump lost well so here's
a couple of questions he any demographic
sorry go ahead if the election is
between a generic Republican and Joe
Biden it's 48 points for the Republican
and 37 for Biden if it's Trump versus
any other Democrat ratic candidate it's
46 for the Democrat and 40 for Trump and
I don't know if they asked the inverse
question I think it's just those two
because I'd be interested if it was
uh if it's uh Joe Biden versus Trump but
it's probably somewhere in the poll but
that right there is interesting enough
but anyway continue what was your
question oh I'm always curious to see
like it's great that he's gaining I'm
also curious to see where there any are
any potential losses right or is it just
Joe Biden who's losing supporters I mean
this was a poll a couple months ago we
saw a swing state pole that had of like
what was it six swing States and it had
Trump up in Georgia Pennsylvania Arizona
and down in
Wisconsin which was like the one state
that Biden won of the Swing States and
I'm missing one in my Michigan yeah I'm
missing Michigan that's right and you
had Trump up in Michigan as well yeah so
and and he's winning Nevada too he's I
think he's up like I think he's up like
six or seven points in Nevada as well
which is and Wisconsin was the whitest
state of the state's surveyed so that
was sort of interesting as well yeah I
mean so so I think I think they're
saying uh right now they got Trump up
two points against Biden is that the
same one that has those same because I I
know the numbers on the demographics are
spoton because I I I have a photographic
memory when it comes to that so um does
it have the breakdown by the black vote
the 18 to 34 that's what I'm looking for
that was that was the the generic right
now they're saying Trump's up two and so
real real clear politics is showing
Trump's averaging 2.6 points above Joe
Biden a lot can happen in the year A lot
can
happen keep try and find the uh
breakdown by race if they have it I
don't know a lot of this is just the
general questions I know Ras M had a
poll in the beginning of October because
I I literally bought their Platinum
package just to be able to read this
poll they had Trump winning 51% of the
black vote yeah I I remember that the
number of random subscriptions I have
and then it's like I don't even remember
how I subscribed I have no idea how to
cancel it hey look at this you or
someone else in your household owns a
gun of any kind 52 applies 43 does not
apply that's interesting gun rights baby
people in this country want to be able
to own
guns yeah Democrats trying to take him
away it's going to piss him off and they
don't like Joe Biden I mean Joe Biden is
intensely unpopular poll show this over
and over again the fact that there was a
majority of Democrats were like no he's
too old to be president that does not
bode well for a re-election campaign he
only gets old
yeah the the one concern that I would
have about um you know declaring a trump
Victory prematurely would be uh that I
think Gavin Newsome would be a wild card
and I don't know what would happen there
I know a lot of people that um you know
that I talk to who are not really
conservative but they're also not really
liberal they really don't like Joe Biden
they also don't like Trump and I think
they would grab at a chance to vote for
somebody they've never heard of who
might have a
reasonabl smile like Gavin Nome I think
they had to have heard of Gavin Newsome
though I mean especially after Francisco
you know you don't hear of them the same
way and if you're not that engaged in
politics you'd know like oh Gavin
Newsome he's the he's the governor of
California and California's fine it's he
had one big viral moment when he was
doing his um acceptance speech or his
like inaugural address and his I
remember it went viral because PE I
think a lot of the country didn't really
know him and his son like came up on
stage people were like how funny how
cute this young you know tall governor
and this you know adorable child and
he's he's a dad and a politician and for
Californians they're like no we don't
like that guy and people in neighboring
states know it but the average American
who's just in the midwest who doesn't
care about California that much just saw
it as this like oh he's the guy with the
kids right and they forgot all about
French Laundry and how he was totally um
pushing covid mandates on everybody but
doing whatever he pleased himself
including sending his kids to private
school schools that were not closed
during the pandemic mhm i w with with
everything that that Newsome that you
hear about California Prop 47 and all
the crime that's running rampant there
coming out and saying oh yeah yeah XI
jingping is coming over here so we we
just moved all the homeless people we
can't do it for you guys but we did it
for him and he said like at the time he
was like oh you've been hearing rumors
that we did this because the pretty
people are coming to town and we did
that is why fancy people and not pretty
people they're not pretty but fancy yeah
and he confirmed that that was in fact
true and it was a nice little chuckle oh
look he's telling the truth how about
that what a guy didn't he like delay
vaccinating his kids even though every
other kid all the other students in
California yeah there was also didn't
wear a mask yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net